[Música]
quando falamos de grandes cidades e
metrópoles
o que nos vem à cabeça são imagens de
carros hoje asfalto prédios seja dos
concretos ou seja uma verdadeira selva
de pedras
mesmo nós que moramos no brasil temos
paisagens naturais muito interligadas às
formas urbanas
percebemos que não tem aqui não temos
referências entre a produção de
alimentos e agricultura dentro da cidade
por sua vez quando falamos de
agricultura o que nos vem à cabeça são
imagens de produções agrícolas do campo
algo que aparentemente está distante de
nós mas por que isso acontece porque de
fato a gente está desacostumado a ver
agricultura dentro das grandes cidades
mas principalmente a gente está
desacostumado a perceber o potencial que
as grandes cidades possuem e os seus
mais variados espaços também para a
produção real de alimentos orgânicos
livres de qualquer veneno ou seja
agrotóxicos
algumas pessoas optam por permanecer
cegas a isso e negar esse potencial
mantendo agricultura afastada de dentro
da cidade
outras pessoas por sua vez ignoram isso
que buscam colocar a mão na terra
independente de onde esteja eu sou uma
delas
estou aqui hoje vou fazer isso mas vocês
também podem ser uma dessas pessoas
e sabe por quê porque é simples porque é
divertido e porque é prazeroso quando a
gente eu que vem lá do rio vocês já
devem ter percebido nos múltiplos s
é eu costumo brincar com os meus amigos
que quando a gente fala de agricultura
a gente pode falar mas a gente pode
falar fazendo fica muito mais divertido
então é isso que vou fazer agora com
vocês
mostrando como a gente pode trabalhar
com um vaso e sybase por exemplo ele
poderia tá em diversos lugares
mesmo em um apartamento eu consigo
cantar esse vaso mas já
ela numa varanda um terraço numa área de
serviço ou até mesmo pendurar ele numa
parede
os exemplos são múltiplos mas o que eu
vou plantar aqui dentro de si vaso e
aqui que moro mais uma das grandes
sacadas que a gente tem que perceber eu
vou plantar o que eu tenho fome de comer
porque o que a fome se torna uma ótima
justificativa para que eu vá lá no meu
vaso cuidar dele e colheu mesmo plantei
eu tenho fome de rúcula então quanto
rúcula pra burro
só que não é só nossa fome que vai dizer
o que eu vou poder plantar esse vaso
eu tenho que unir com outros fatores são
cinco critérios bem fácil que cabem na
palma da minha mão
a insolação do local onde eu quero
plantar o espaço físico do vaso e
obviamente do local também a forma da
minha espécie
o tempo de vida dela e por último
obviamente quem é que vai cuidar desse
vazio porque ele não quer ficar
abandonado
agora se eu tenho fome de uma coisa e
vocês têm fome de outro então nosso
objetivo é ser diferente se na minha
casa tem uma quantidade de sol e na casa
de vocês têm uma quantidade menor
então nosso plantio também vai ser
diferente e adivinha isso é perfeito
sabe por quê os exemplo os inúmeros
exemplos de agricultura urbana que tem
na cidade nos mostram essa ideia uma
idéia da não receita do modelo
agricultura não há uma receita de bolo
eu gosto de comer uma coisa vocês gostam
de outro eu moro no lugar de vocês moram
em outro então a gente tem que observar
quais são as particularidades de cada
lugar
o que eu desejo comer e sim obviamente
os princípios básicos para que eu possa
fazer esse plantio
independente de onde esteja agora eu vou
então começar a plantar de fato no vaso
e partir para a ação
esse aqui é um vaso de fibra de coco que
como é feito de um material impermeável
não necessita que eu faça um furo em
baixo porque a água naturalmente vai
embora por ele ela passa por esse
material e vai embora e drena quando eu
tenho um vaso de plástico a primeira
coisa que eu tenho que fazer por ele ser
um material impermeável é fazer dois
furos embaixo do vaso
esse esforço vão me ajudar com que a
água saia desse vaso
depois que eu faço os furos eu boto
argilas expandidos
todo mundo conhece bem essas argilas
dever da justiça
com essas argilas eu consigo fazer o
fundo do vaso proteger o furo no caso
quando ele tem furo para que a água não
vai embora com terra e facilita a
drenagem desse vazio também a partir do
momento que eu plantei que eu botei a
argila expandida aqui dentro eu posso
entrar então a minha terra
essa terra é bom é bom que seja uma
terra preta adubada
e aqui é importante prestar atenção pra
gente não colocar toda a terra de uma
vez que ainda vou botar muda e elas
ocupam um espaço então o bota terra até
cobrir em argila expandida
na cidade há inúmeros exemplos de
plantios como esse em vasos e outros que
acontecem em praças quintais canteiro de
terraços ruas viadutos
a gente pode estar no rio de janeiro e
nova york por exemplo no rio de janeiro
a gente tem hortas em praças como horta
nossa e também horta do cosme velho e em
nova york tem um dos principais exemplos
e de hortas em telhados que é o bruto em
grande o top five
ele fica localizado no bairro do
brooklin em nova york numa área de
aproximadamente 2 mil metros quadrados
onde a comunidade planta neste lado ea
partir disso ela pode lá acolher os
alimentos pode continuar ajudando
plantando mais pode trabalhar lá
inclusive pode escolher pegar ovos das
galinhas que vivem ali dentro daquele
telhado
a gente está conseguindo no caso da
casinha delas agora mas elas estão lá
assim como no rio assim como nova iorque
no rio além das praças que eu falei pra
vocês a gente também tem exemplo do
projeto altitude onde o meu coletivo
karp junto com o clube orgânico resolveu
ganhar asas e também sobre os telhados
então a idéia é pegar telhados verdes ou
telhados que não tem nenhum verde na
cidade do rio de janeiro e
transformá-los em telhados verdes
comestíveis
a idéia é que a comunidade chega junto e
que a gente faça um trabalho
principalmente para eles e esse trabalho
de certa forma e principalmente um
trabalho com muito prazer interno e
muito amor incondicional
e eu não estou falando isso à toa pra
vocês porque são os sentimentos ou
emoções boas estou falando isso porque é
uma base filosófica que a gente aprendeu
com grande mestre da cap que werritty
gatti
ele é um suíço que mora há 30 anos no
brasil no sul da bahia em piraí do norte
ea partir do seu trabalho ele conseguiu
recuperar uma área de floresta de
aproximadamente 500 hectares
ele comprou 30 anos atrás a fazenda
fugido da terra seca
infelizmente esse nome infelizmente ela
não existe mais
aí vocês vão perguntar por que ele não
deu certo trabalho dele pelo contrário
deu muito certo
a fazenda fugidos da terra seca se
transformou na fazenda olho d'água oeste
a partir do seu trabalho agrofloresta
conseguiu plantar água e não é
brincadeira ele plantou floresta ea
floresta traz água de volta
isso é evidente e isso é um fato na
fazenda dele ele recuperou mais de 14
nascente
a partir desse trabalho ele mostra pra
gente que é muito mais fácil que a gente
pode criar recursos ao invés de
simplesmente consumi los
isso é ser sim trópico e oeste é um
exemplo disso é um exemplo dessas
entropia e do trabalho com prazer
interno e amor incondicional
considerando principalmente que as
espécies podem cooperar
então a gente pode sim plantar uma
floresta esperar que ela possa me
retornar - ou seja nos aproximadamente
500 hectares de floresta que era
espantoso
são 500 hectares aproximado de floresta
comestível a gente ana clara fala pela
floresta podendo comer o que ela está
nos dando eu fico o dia inteiro na
floresta trabalhando colhendo cacau e
fico com sede
eu vou lá e posso pegar um limão boi e
comer pra matar ou seja posso pegar uma
laranja e também chutar para matar a
sede e por aí vai os exemplos são
inúmeros
então agrofloresta basicamente ela
trabalha com a idéia de a gente pegar as
dinâmicas florestais e juntar com os
processos agrícolas de produção de
alimento
então o agro com floresta por isso a
água floresta
agora você está olhando por esse vaso
vocês vão com certeza imaginando que eu
não
conseguir plantar uma árvore aqui não
vou conseguir fazer uma floresta real
nesse vaso mas eu posso fazer uma mini
floresta e essa intenção que a gente vai
fazer uma mini florestinha
então a partir dos conceitos técnicos de
alguns conceitos técnicos da água
floresta
a gente vai se inspirar neles pra poder
fazer o nosso plantio na cidade o que eu
vou fazer aqui
a partir do primeiro conceito que o
consórcio entre as espécies
eu vou plantar mais de uma espécie junta
espécies diferentes uma da outra
então aqui eu tenho tomilho eu tenho
alecrim e orégano
provavelmente todos vocês conhecem esse
tempero é possível eu ter a proteção dos
empregos dentro do vaso
agora porque como eu vou contar eles
juntos porque eu posso contar juntos a
gente entra no segundo conceito técnico
da agrofloresta que a gente transpõe
para a cidade que é a estratificação a
estratificação basicamente se refere à
forma física que essas espécies assumir
e à altura que elas vão ocupar de acordo
com a quantidade de luz que elas
necessitam e isso também é com certeza
vai orientar a forma física que essa
planta vai ter então dessa desse modo eu
consigo cantar o tomilho que tem uma
forma de cabelo que fica caindo bem do
lado bem próximo do alecrim que tem uma
forma arbustiva e do outro lado já
consigo vim com orégano que têm a mesma
forma de se distribuir de um cabelo
se eu tivesse quisesse colocar o plantio
assim iria me atrapalhar
mas eu colocando o plantio com espécies
com forma diferente
isso me ajuda e ela não vai conflitar
entre elas então para fazer o plantio ou
simplesmente tiro o que a gente chama de
torrão dessa dessa mudinha do plástico
deixo ela onde eu quero posicionam ela
tira o meu alecrim posiciono ele da
mesma forma faço isso com meu orégano e
a partir disso já consigo continuar
preenchendo mil vasos com terra
nessa hora é interessante a gente
conseguir preencher com a terra até o
topo até o topo da mud que a gente
plantou
e a gente vai botando uma diversão pra
mim sujar as mãos
parece brincadeira mas não é eu vou
conversando com elas
só não esperem que elas falem português
com você está bom gente planta não fala
desculpa a gente se comunica com elas
mas não é através do português da floral
mas aqui com a minha mão com energia que
estou colocando e com prazer interno
amor incondicional eu consigo me
comunicar para elas com elas e facilitar
esse plantio facilitar com que ela se
desenvolveu bem esse vaso pronto eu dou
uma leve pressionada só precisou ficar
firme aqui dentro mas não é pra apertar
o favor não fiquem apertando sem parar
eu dou uma leve pressionada e assim eu
consigo fazer o plantio das mudas
só que como eu falei pra vocês a minha
intenção é fazer uma mini florestinha e
agora vou usar o terceiro conceito
técnico da água floresta que é a
sucessão natural entre as espécies
ou seja eu vou plantar espécies com o
tempo de vida diferente porque porque
uma vai criar outra então quando vou
plantar uma semente e uma muda do lado a
muda vai ajudar semente é somente vai
ajudar muda então elas têm uma uma
cooperação entre elas de ajuda mútua e o
que vai acontecer conforme essa semente
foi crescendo eu vou colhendo a minha
muda quando eu acabar de colherinha
mudou ela naturalmente morrer porque o
tempo de vida dela se esgotou
quem vai suceder elas são as sementes
que eu plantei nesse caso de vínculo com
talula porque eu gosto muito de rúcula
então não podia deixar de plantar rúcula
quando vocês forem plantar sementes
sempre se atentem para uma coisa quando
forem comprar pacotes por favor sempre
sem defensivos ou sem imagem da
cadeirinha
infelizmente defensiva período moderno
para veneno por agrotóxico e não tem
nenhum agrotóxico que seja bom pra gente
comer muito menos a aplicar na terra uma
vez que a nossa pele é a maior boca que
a gente tem então eu tô trabalhando com
agrotóxico ou ingerindo ele da mesma
forma
além dos pacotinhos em aveiro sem
defensivos por favor também busquem
trabalhar com espécies de sementes
crioulas que são espécies produzidas
pelos agricultores ou redes ecológicas e
não foram modificadas geneticamente
não são espécies sementes artificiais
são os elementos de fato naturais
preservados
a partir da agricultura de anos eu pego
essa semente e aí comeu dedo mindinho
eu vou fazer um buraco entre as mudas e
aqui eu vou plantar a semente de rúcula
basicamente eu tenho que pegar esse
saquinho e verá na canaleta que eu fiz
com meu dedo mindinho então você vem
abre uma canaleta que seu dedo mindinho
joga somente e depois com o dedo
mindinho em volta à terra tá então já
plantei tomilho alecrim orégano eu ainda
vou contar mais coisa eu vou plantar
agora o tomate que inclusive foi
comprado hoje de manhã na feira do lado
então eu vou pegar ele vou estourar ele
aqui mesmo e eu vou botar semente no na
outra canaleta que eu fiz
dessa forma posso fechar de novo a
canaleta deixar as minhas sementes
enterrados perfeito
por último para a gente finalizar a
gente vai contar uma raiz que é o
gengibre uma vez plantadas gengibre
praticamente não precisa mais comprar a
gente pega e se o linho que esses brotos
que sair a gente chama de olho cortam
deles e planta um bota dentro da terra
com um olho para baixo e depois é só
cobrir de novo lembrando sempre de botar
onde você não colocou e somente então a
atenção é muito importante nessas horas
também já plantou menos mudas já plantou
uma semente já plantei minha raiz de
gengibre
agora a gente pode partir para a quarta
o quarto conceito técnico que a
cobertura da minha terra com matéria
orgânica
essa matéria orgânica é uma matéria
orgânica verde e seca folhas verdes
secas picotadas isso você consegue
andando na rua com uma tesoura uma
sacola é simples
com essas folhas a gente vai pegando e
vai cobrir no nosso solo e vai cobrir na
nossa terra
dessa forma a gente cria um sistema
retroalimentar onde quando a composição
natural dessas folhas
ele vai fornecer nutrientes para o vaso
ou seja ele vai ajudar com que as
plantas que esteja apontando fiquem
saudáveis
além disso de proporcionar um sistema
retroalimentar ele vai proteger a minha
terra do contato direto com a água o que
deixa ela compactada e também permeável
uma vez que ela fica uma lâmina
compactada não entra mais água dela e
também vai me ajudar a reter a água da
minha ligação porque porque ela funciona
como uma espécie de esponja
nesse caso eu vou jogar água e ela vai
ficar liberando aos poucos essa água
então ela vai reter essa água como se
fosse uma esponja e vai ajudar a
preservar a unidade do meu solo do vaso
então foi muito simples esse pontinho
para terminar o que a gente vai fazer
e todo mundo deve estar imaginando a
gente vai ligar
então eu pego um regador e é bom usar de
fato o jogador não copo porque eu quero
que faça essa chuvinha
eu não quero que a água caia direto como
uma cachoeira
pronto tá ligado e assim a gente tem um
vaso espantado
parece besteira montar meu próprio
tempero mas não é
a gente não percebe mas em média a gente
paga 34 reais um saquinho de 100 200
gramas de alecrim
ou seja a gente está pagando 30 reais no
quilo é praticamente o valor de uma peça
de filé mignon
olha o que eu consegui fazer em 18
minutos
agora imagina o que a gente não consegue
fazer juntos um dia uma semana em um mês
nos mais variados espaços da cidade a
gente sim consegue contar muita coisa
com isso as cidades atualmente elas
perderam muitos vêm perdendo cada vez
mais sua capacidade de resiliência e
regeneração
quando nós plantamos que nós comemos nós
nos reger anos quando nós fazemos isso
na cidade nós certa forma começamos a
resgatar parte da sua capacidade de
resiliência e regeneração
infelizmente infelizmente a gente tem
essa possibilidade de plantar gerar
recursos e criar recurso
eu tenho muita fome de plantio muita
mesmo
e quando a gente a compra ainda de
agricultores locais o plamta a nossa
própria comida e se torna um ato de
resistência quando a gente faz
agrofloresta agricultura em troca
proposta pela uerj é um ato de
a cooperação e amor incondicional
então a proposta que eu deixo para vocês
é que juntos nós queremos mais espaços
de cooperação de amor incondicional e de
resistência
vamos juntos plantar o que queremos
comer
nós somos o que comemos então nós também
somos o que plantamos
obrigado
[Aplausos]